over the course of the 1600s the English
continued to settle along the eastern
seaboard of North America now we've
already talked about the settlements at
Virginia and those of Massachusetts and
a little bit about the settlement of New
York which was first founded by the
Dutch as New Amsterdam in 1624 in this
video I want to talk a little bit more
about the middle colonies these colonies
that were here kind of on the centre of
the eastern seaboard south of
Massachusetts and north of the southern
colonies of Virginia particularly
Pennsylvania New York New Jersey and
this little tiny purple colony right
here Delaware now what's unique about
the middle colonies compared to the
northern or southern colonies is not
just that they were kind of in this
central location but also that they were
proprietary colonies which means that
they were the property of individual
owners so unlike Jamestown for example
which was founded by a company the
Virginia Company the colony of
Pennsylvania was founded by one man
William Penn
who was granted his land by the king of
England
in exchange for a debt that the king had
owed his father so in the early years of
these proprietary colonies they were
kind of the playgrounds of the people
who owned them they could set their own
rules for the most part and that freedom
resulted in colonies that were more
ethnically diverse and more religiously
tolerant than their neighbors to the
north or south so let's look at the
colony of Pennsylvania as an example so
Pennsylvania was founded by William Penn
and Penn was a English aristocrat from a
very good family who'd converted to the
Quaker religion
although the real name for Quakers was
the religious Society of Friends they
got the nickname Quaker because they
seemed to quake when they were in
religious ecstasy like the Puritans
Quakers faced religious persecution in
England because they did not follow the
Church of England which was a form of
rebellion against the king who was the
head of the Church of England but in
addition to the Quakers strange ideas
about religion they also had some
strange ideas for the time period about
social status Quakers believed that all
people had the light of God in them and
therefore were more or less equal in
stature so for example women could
preach in church as you see in this
image right here so when william penn
converted to the Quaker faith Penn had a
really rough time of it so he came upon
an idea that perhaps he could make a
haven for Quakers and for religious
dissenters more broadly in the new world
so he negotiated with the king who owed
his father a debt and in exchange for
this debt the King granted Penn land in
North America which was named
Pennsylvania Sylvania being Latin for
forests so kind of Penn's forest pens
woods and pen decided to extend his
religious tolerance not just to Quakers
but really to all people all Protestants
no matter what their particular sect
could have citizenship run for office
vote and Catholics and even Jews were
welcome in Pennsylvania although they
did not have the right to vote or hold
office this was incredibly radical for
the time period when it was common for
nations to have a state religion and to
persecute those who didn't follow that
religion Penn advertised for his new
colony and particularly hoped that
industrious people people with skills
like carpentry blacksmithing would come
to Pennsylvania and make it a prosperous
colony and they did the ease of getting
citizenship the religious tolerance and
the plentiful and cheap land of
Pennsylvania drew many settlers to the
colonies such that its principal city
Philadelphia was the largest city in
North America before the Revolution with
about 40,000 inhabitants because Quakers
were pacifists that is they did not
believe in violence or war they even
lived peacefully with Native Americans
in the early years of Pennsylvania
settlement but as more immigrants of
different faiths came to Pennsylvania
and began pushing West that short era of
peaceful cohabitation ended likewise
because Quakers believed in the innate
Equality of all human beings they were
not fond of slavery the environment in
the middle colonies was not so cold as
it was in the north not so hot as it was
in the south it was kind of middling and
so it was a very good place for farming
particularly cereal crops like wheat you
can see this print here shows wheat
growing in this field and just as the
name suggests Pennsylvania had a lot of
wood so it was also a good place for
timber and the excellent ports at
Philadelphia and New York City made it
an excellent place for trade because it
was such a good place to grow food the
middle colonies got the nickname the
breadbasket colonies and the patterns of
land ownership reflect this since the
soil was good your average farmer owns
more land than
New England farmer but not as much as a
Virginia farmer who would have had many
acres to grow tobacco so much like the
environment the farms in the middle
colonies were middling in size in fact
if I had to put the middle colonies on a
spectrum in many places I'd put them
right in the middle when it came to
economy that was more agrarian the
middle colonies had a little bit of both
unlike the Chesapeake and southern
economies which were strongly agrarian
and unlike the New England colonies who
began manufacturing quite early
likewise when it comes to the
distribution of wealth in the middle
colonies once again I'd put the middle
colonies right here in the center there
were plenty of middling farmers many
indentured servants and a handful of
people who became quite wealthy
unlike the Chesapeake where there were a
handful of extremely wealthy landowners
while most people lived at the bottom of
the social scale and unlike New England
where small farming led to a fairly even
middle-class so the middle colonies had
a mixed economy of Industry and farming
and a fairly balanced class structure
with people at many different levels
putting them smack dab in the middle but
for all the ways that the middle
colonies were middle either were also a
few ways that they were quite
extraordinary we've already mentioned
that the middle colonies had a level of
religious freedom that was virtually
unmatched anywhere else in the world
for example Pennsylvania extended
citizenship to all Protestants and
tolerated Catholics and Jews in
comparison the Chesapeake and southern
colonies
required citizens to belong to the
Anglican faith the Church of England and
religious tolerance board the Catholic
Church in Maryland and New Englanders
were extremely strict for example in
Massachusetts Bay anyone who was not
Puritan was expelled or executed
although there is of course the
exception of Rhode Island where
religious dissenters could find safe
haven the other extraordinary aspect of
these middle colonies was just the sheer
amount of ethnic diversity there was by
the time of the American Revolution less
than half way about 49 percent of
inhabitants were from England or had an
English background the rest were German
French Dutch Scotch Irish and just a few
Africans as there was a relatively
little slavery in comparison New England
was perhaps the least diverse of the
colonies
most people were English with a handful
of remaining Native Americans and
Africans and the Chesapeake and southern
colonies were largely African and
English with again just a few Native
Americans the people of the middle
colonies spoke many languages practiced
many faiths and had a strong possibility
of upward mobility economically since
farms and businesses prospered and the
middle colonies grew rapidly in
population